Welcome everyone and thank you all
for coming to today's talk. Uh,
my name is Mike Diamond and I'm a manager
in the Google advertiser platforms
division focusing on
programmatic strategy. Um,
and I'm really excited and honored
to be moderating today's talk. Um,
I've been a member of the
Leadership Council for an
organization called upwardly
global, uh, for the past nine
or so years. The organization,
um,
helps refugees and immigrants
find meaningful work in
the u s that's requisite
with their skills and experience.
And when I think about,
um, when I first got involved
with the organization,
it's amazing because there was really
very little coverage of refugees and
immigrants. Um, it took
me a matter of five,
10 minutes to truly explain
the organization's mission. Um,
but over the past year, uh, with
the dailies of media attention,
there's been an increasing focus
on refugees and immigrants,
not only in the US but around the world.
Um,
and it's been quite a tumultuous
time for both of those groups.
And refugees in particular have been in
the spotlight both here and abroad and
for good reason.
Uh,
worldwide displacement is that an
absolute all time high with simply record
numbers. They're staggering. Um,
one in nearly every hundred and 22
people around the globe is either refugee
internally displaced or seeking asylum.
65 and a half million people
have been forcibly displaced,
which is a 60% increase
from just a decade ago.
And over 22 million of those are refugees.
So today we welcome two guests who
can help us better contextualize and
understand emerging stories in the media
as well as our country is rhetoric and
policies towards newcomers.
Really New Americans.
Our discussion today is going to be
focused on both refugees and immigrants,
really who they are,
the workforce issues that surround
them and our country's policies,
um,
towards them.
We're going to hope to cover US policy
as well as practices with regards to
resettlement of both refugees and
immigrants will talk about the difference
between differences between refugees,
asylum seekers, migrants and immigrants.
As we often don't talk about the nuance
between those different groups. Um,
and finally talk about some of the support
systems that are here in America to
support these communities.
So without further ado,
let me introduce you to our
two. Uh, our two guests. First,
Suzanne, cause Ori is the senior director
of philanthropy and partnerships at the
American Jewish joint distribution
committee, also known as the JDC.
She's had over 25 years of experience
working in the refugee humanitarian field
and in the course of her career has
worked for three of the nine resettlement
agencies in the u s um,
Maine and managing various aspects
of their resettlement programs.
She attended Wellesley college and,
uh,
also received
her degree from the Fletcher School of
Law and Diplomacy at Tufts University St.
Next to me as Nikki says,
Ronnie,
who I've known for many years and
as the CEO of upwardly global,
um, where she's worked for the,
for the past eight plus years,
as we'll hear later,
uh,
upclose work grew out of the resettlement
system and as the first and longest
serving organization to support the
integration of skilled refugees and
immigrants into the u s
workforce. Um, Nikki has her, uh,
received her MBA from Columbia,
uh,
and has a bachelor's degree in
policy analysis from Cornell.
So to kick things off,
um,
I like to just baseline a little bit on
resettlement as a topic in general and
it turned to Suzanne.
Um,
we'd love you to kind of help us get an
understanding of the refugee situation
both globally and here in the u s and
start to understand why displacement has
grown so much over the past,
particularly 10 years or so.
Okay. Um, hello everybody. So, um,
I'll focus on resettlement in
the u s but just for perspective,
the situation right now in Syria is
definitely the thing that has turned the
pendulum and really ramped up the,
the desperation and the
situation for refugees worldwide.
But really we live in a world where
there's much less peacebuilding.
There's so much more
persecution than ever before,
but also we don't address the root causes
so that people can go back. I mean,
many of us remember situations in Vietnam,
in Bosnia,
in Rwanda where refugees
returned to their homes.
There is less and less of that today.
So today we still see millions of
refugees that have left Afghanistan.
How many of you even remember
when Afghanistan happened?
That was way back in the 1980s some
of you weren't even born Sudan,
Somalia, all these things,
these refugee crisis,
we're so protracted and we haven't dealt
with the peace building side of it.
And so refugees are just basically some
of my colleagues call it warehouse in
refugee camps or in cities around the
world in poor countries and neighboring
countries. And that's just persisted for
so long. So there's a been a buildup,
but very few solutions at,
at the root causes. Um,
very few refugees are resettled. So
if the numbers, you mentioned Mike,
maybe 1% only get resettled and
it's like a lottery in a sense.
If you get out of your country and have
a chance at third country resettlement,
many refugees,
most of them,
the bulk of them are in
neighboring countries where
really it's hard to welcome
them because the neighboring countries
are poor and it's just such millions and
millions of people who need jobs,
need livelihoods,
need food, clothing, et cetera.
And refugees don't want to
be recipients of welfare.
They want to be able to have a
chance at continuing their lives.
That's why organizations
like yours are so important.
But all of our work is so important.
So in the US,
the US resettlement program traditionally
has been different than other
countries because our focus is
employment almost to our detriment.
Um, so the agencies, there's nine
resettlement agencies in America,
there were more before
the fall of communism,
but now there's nine.
Most of them are faith based
and three of them are not.
So their church World Service,
um,
Hebrew immigrant aid society,
Lutheran Immigration Refugee Services,
US Catholic conference, world's
relief. The Evangelical Group,
they don't proselytize.
But the reason they're important is that
there are churches and constituents all
over the country that welcome refugees.
And the other three that
are nondenominational are
they international rescue
committee, US Conference for Refugees.
And there's an Ethiopian group,
Ethiopian community and Development
Group that does the same work committee.
So all of them have sponsors around the
country that help with the resettlement.
So they are professional staff and sponsor
because the resettlement program in
America is a private public partnership.
The idea is it's so important to welcome
refugees in your community and you
don't want to impact any one
community in the country.
Usually if refugees had their choices,
they'd all go to Florida,
California cause they're warm in their
minds and maybe New York because it's so
receptive,
but welfare is such in some of these
states that it's so generous that really
the system is geared in such a way that
refugees who don't have family members
usually have to go to states where they
have hospitable communities to welcome
them and to work with the professional
staff like these nine agencies.
And what we're responsible for doing is
refugees are recognized as refugees by
State Department overseas.
They don't,
it's asylum seekers that
come to the u s borders,
but refugees are recognize it's part
of the u s foreign policy to recognize
people of humanitarian concern to the u
s so it's usually countries that America
realizes are persecuting
its own populations.
The president of the United States
and congress set the ceilings,
the numbers of people who get to come
in and basically they're processed
overseas. It's a long, long, long process.
All of you have heard that
screening people for um,
admissions to the u s is very complicated
because you have to go through a lot
of security clearances.
Basically you go through a UN agency
called the UN High Commissioner for
refugees who then refers
you for resettlement to one
of many countries in the
world.
Your papers go through.
Some refugees have been there 10 2030
years before they even arrived to America,
especially those coming in from Africa.
Some come in about two,
three years, which is considered very
fast after waiting and they come here,
we receive them.
The resettlement agencies basically
received them with sponsors in America.
The responsibilities are to get
people employed as soon as possible.
And for that reason they usually
take very low paying jobs.
The bar is to try and get jobs that
will help people become self sufficient
enough money to pay for your rent.
And basically over a longer timeframe,
a longer arc in your life.
You start learning the English,
you start doing all those other things
and you slowly, slowly move up the ladder.
So it's, it's, it's a difficult thing,
but that's the emphasis of the u s program
and some of the countries in Europe,
they would rather a refugee, go on welfare
then get the job of a local person.
But in the states,
that's not the way we do it.
We do it with a real emphasis
on early self-sufficiency. Um,
so that basically,
and so when refugees come in,
the resettlement agencies within 90
to 120 days have to get you a job,
help you with an apartment.
And remember it's not just
through State Department money,
it's a lot of the goodwill of American
people and neighbors and communities get
you jobs,
social security numbers,
help enroll kids in school help connect
you to your community because nobody
wants refugees to live in isolation.
You both want a host community and the
community that might be existing like an
ethnic community that can speak the
same language so they can have access to
food that's familiar to them.
So basically the program runs for
the most part really beautifully.
But with the idea that you give
the minimum over the long term,
there are other social services
that refugees can access,
state employment programs,
ESL programs, et cetera.
And that goes on for a long time.
But it takes organizations like
upwardly global that have that specific
understanding of what
kind of support system.
Somebody trying to get a new job and
move up in the market really requires.
And so organizations like this are more
and more important to make sure that
refugees are not an underclass. Cause
as Mike said, there are new Americans,
they're not refugees
when they arrive here.
We've selected them as people who will
be part of our communities and many,
many contribute immediately to,
sorry,
it was a long,
long
response, but it's a big issue. Yeah.
Can you tell us a little bit more
about the profile of refugees?
So are they families, individuals? Like
what does that, what does that look like?
Okay,
so in general,
um,
it's a difficult question to answer it.
The UN High Commissioner for Refugees
used to have these posters and said,
says these are refugees and there
would be these little puppets,
pictures of anybody you can imagine.
So because basically when
you have a refugee crisis,
it's everybody. So it, it
could be anyone who's a Moslem.
Anyone who's a Christian,
anyone who's a Jew and from all classes,
it doesn't discriminate.
Governments don't discriminate just
by class. So it's basically everyone.
Um, more than half are
probably children. Um,
most coming to the u s are families.
There are situations and places where
single people are coming primarily
because of maybe specific persecution
that had government has inflicted on a
certain group. But genuinely it's
mostly families, but it's everybody.
It's carpenters, it's
journalists, it's everybody.
It's anybody.
We started mentioning,
I know you've worked for a number
of the resettlement organizations.
Can you tell us a little bit about the
process that those ordination go through
to, to help families? To help individuals?
Okay.
So most important is having volunteers,
having people to support refugees.
That's one of the most important things.
We usually realize it.
Again,
another aspect of the American program
at Visa VI refugees is priority's given
to people who have family members in
the u s because they're obviously the
biggest support system and then your
community and volunteers are the other
support system.
So for church based organizations you
can have many churches helping with
sponsorship. So mentoring
kids in school, um,
uh, mentoring families, helping families.
There's a lot of psychosocial issues
that maybe people are suffering from
isolation, depression. So it
really helps to be integrated.
Um,
the church based agencies I've worked
for often have used church sponsors or
community connections,
but a church agency,
we'll also work with a mosque if you have,
um,
you bring in a lot of interfaith groups
because you don't want people to just be
labeled and just be
ghettoized when they come.
It's really so important as many
more people as you can bring in.
The more important it is,
and maybe the single most
important aspect is financial,
which is helping people get jobs,
helping women with maybe five children,
find childcare.
So they really,
the agencies help with
all of that very much.
In the beginning the expectations of
the organizations are all the same.
So whether I worked for a church based
agency or the international rescue
committee,
the basic factors,
we all have to give a certain standard
of service to make sure that people are
self sufficient or know where to go and
get services so they're not on their own
because there's a lot of support systems
from the state that also are available
to people. And just a quick follow up,
how long do those support systems last?
It's very short in terms
of the contract with which,
let's say the resettlement agencies
have with State Department,
so it's between 90 to 120 days that
the relationship really is there.
And then the rest of it is referrals
and passing things on to state and city
actors or private actors like upwardly
global who come in and help out and pick
people up to the next step and next level.
And some of the organizations
have longer term contracts.
They may have employment contracts from
the state or from the city because there
is an understanding by many states and
cities that you require a specific kind
of understanding and language experience
and cultural experience to help with
these things.
In your experience,
what do you think some of the biggest
challenges that the organizations face as
they're trying to help some of these
groups? Okay, so, so today and I,
I bet everyone would have the same
response is it's just this feeling of fear
and feeling that you're not welcome.
I should also tell you that refugees
when they're fleeing their countries very
often don't want to go
to a western country.
And most people think they do know they
want to be right by their homes so they
can go back home tomorrow.
And the fact is after 10 20 years,
five years, you stop thinking that
even with the Syrian refugees was very,
very difficult for the Western world
to convince them that you have been so
persecuted, you're unlikely
to go back home. You know,
resettlement might be the right thing
for you. You have a chance at a new life.
And most people make those decisions for
their children because they know that
going back is not an option.
Um,
so the challenges to me
are isolating people fear.
Um,
which is part of what's happening
in today's rhetoric about refugees.
I mean, the idea that you can have a
bag of skittles and one of them can,
can be dangerous is
that that creates fear.
And that's not been the history of
America. So we talk about refugees,
but in America there have been so many
groups that have come in for hundreds and
hundreds of years. Even before there was
an official enactment of refugee law,
we've had immigrants and refugees
coming since this country started.
And there's been backlash,
backlash against the Chinese backlash
against the Irish backlash against the
Italians. I mean, hatred and
vitriol like we hear today.
So actually I'm very positive.
I feel this is part of a
trend that will change,
but I feel that there are moments
in our history that this happens.
But I really believe in what I've
seen everywhere is there is something
unbelievable in America in terms of
how America welcomes the stranger.
Because so many Americans have had the
experience of being a stranger themselves
and it's unbelievable.
We,
so many of us in our family members
have been recipients of that kind of
kindness.
It's nice to hear some of that optimism.
Yeah,
I believe that genuine,
one of the things that's really struck
me through my experience with upwardly
global was how many refugees
and immigrants are highly
educated and are coming
to this country with years and years
of experience and university degrees.
Um,
a stat that I've learned is roughly 28%
of that community has bachelor's degrees
or higher, which is compared to
roughly 29% of the u s population.
Um, the interesting thing is
that despite that expertise,
despite that experience,
so many of these immigrants and
refugees are either unemployed or as,
um, uh, Susana lit it or under employed,
which is a term that we don't really
talk about a lot. Uh, and so, um,
many of them end up being very poor and
that is certainly not a situation that
they deserve. Um, and so when
I think about upwardly global,
I want to kind of transition over to
Nikki, um, to, to talk about, you know,
why that problem exists and how do you
think you have addressed it and can other
organizations kind
of addressed that? Sure, sure. Um,
so I think it's easiest to talk about
the founding of upwardly global because
our founder and I'm not,
the founder of the organization was
working in refugee resettlement and while
resettlement happens through
nine different volunteer
agencies throughout the
country,
the government also has some national
services that help all of those volunteer
agencies do their jobs, particularly with
respect to us. Husan said employment. Um,
our founder was working and that
employment technical assistance to the
volunteer agencies when the
first wave of Bosnians came over.
Now the Bosnian refugee cohort
was relatively highly educated,
um, and it was in seeing that the
system was set up to do what Susan said,
rapid attachment jobs. Those jobs
tend to be low wage, low skill work.
And it was her experience
watching literally surgeons
and engineers wind up in
the front lines of chicken processing
plants where they were considered the best
employees in the organization,
but there was nothing left in the
system to help them get back into their
trained fields. And our founder was sort
of spinning the narrative on its head,
which is not only is it an old romanticize
narrative that the first generation
comes and sacrifices so that the next
generation can enjoy the opportunities
that this country and that that's
a detriment to the individual,
but that that's also a
detriment to the country.
So this was really at
the beginning in which,
I mean we've talked more
and more certainly over the
last decade when I've been
with upwardly global about
a skills gap in the country.
But the vision of our founder
was exactly that, that this is,
this is we're losing out on two sides
when we accept under employment and when
the narrative we build is encouraging
those who are coming with skills to accept
sort of their new station in life.
And that was part of what
happened in the system.
That there was a bit of a
narrative that says, look,
your education from your home country may
just not count here or the the sort of
quicker you sort of accept
your new station in life,
the better your
integration is going to go.
And upwardly global was founded for that
niche of the population where we were
trying to change that narrative by
proving that better outcomes were possible
for refugees. And then as we
sort of grew as an organization,
realizing that the problem existed for
a much broader swath of the immigrant
population.
Um,
so we exist because despite the media
having you believe that every immigrant in
the country might be undocumented or
coming through the h one B process,
most people don't know.
We legally allow about a million people
into the country every year through our
regular immigration channels.
And so our primary immigration policy
in the country is family reunification.
We also of course have a policy of refugee
resettlement where you're getting a
skilled population coming through and
then also the diversity card lottery.
So through those three channels alone,
you get a million people coming in a year.
And of the adult population
of that larger group,
you've got 48% who have a bachelor's
or better and you have drastic
underemployment. So
the, the, on the whole,
if you look at everybody coming in about
one in four windup, under or unemployed.
Um, and then if you look at subgroups
like refugees, those coming from Africa,
Latin America, Middle East, it's
much more drastic than that.
Why does that happen?
So if you start to think about your own
sort of trajectory as a professional and
you start to think about what you needed
in order to get where you're going,
some of those things will not be there
for somebody coming to the country after
they've been educated
and started their career.
So the biggest thing that could
possibly be missing, of course,
his English language skills,
and that's true for about
half the population that
wind up under or unemployed,
is that their English is
simply not sufficient.
Now that doesn't mean
that they're not fluent.
It means that actually there's a big
difference between being good at English
and what they call very good. And I
promise you, these are technical terms,
good is where you can
actually be very conversant.
Somebody understands what you need,
understands how to give it to you because
you can make yourself understood being
very good actually trans aggresses that
and it means you've actually achieved a
level of English where years likely to
speak it in the home as you are your home,
your, your, your home country language.
And it also means that you understand
the contextualized English of your field.
And so when you have English barriers,
I don't want everybody to think that you
have people who don't speak English at
all.
That part of the problem is that English
is not moving people from that good to
very good. Um, in addition to that,
one of the biggest barriers that
newcomers face is a lack of a professional
network. Think about how you
found your job here at Google.
Um, it could be that a recruiter
saw you on linkedin and called you.
It could be that they found that profile
on linkedin through somebody else.
They were looking at it on
linkedin. Um, but in most cases,
as we progress through our careers,
we use our network to find our
next job or an opening in that job.
When you come to resettlement, when you
come through family reunification, you,
you're less likely to have
that professional network.
And then there's other
barriers. Um, a culturation, uh,
the job search is very different here
in the u s than it may be another
countries.
So a very classic example.
I don't know if we have anybody who
was educated outside the u s experience
outside the u s but your resume may
have its picture on it, marital status,
religious affiliation. Um, it's
not atypical to have a five, six,
seven, even eight page resume and
from certain parts of the world.
And then if you just start to think
about the nuance of American culture,
we are typically self promoting.
Um, meaning that we don't,
we don't shy away from talking about
accomplishments of yourself or your team.
Um, but that you have to actually do
that. We express enthusiasm about a job.
We tend not to be as
hierarchical as other cultures.
So our interview processes require
that we ask the interviewer questions,
things that may feel odd
coming from other types of, um,
cultures where that's just
not done in the job search.
And so what you have is this no network,
uh,
resume and set of job search skills that
are not working here. And then finally,
what you have is you have a
misunderstanding of foreign education.
Foreign degree simply in most cases is
not as highly prized and or understood as
a US degree.
And so when you're coming with a Middle
Eastern name and the University of
Baghdad on your resume,
an employer may see that and
simply not know what to do with it.
And that's the kind of
innocuous, uh, version.
And then the non innocuous one is his
subconscious and even conscious bias.
We're here in New York City.
Sometimes it's hard for us to
really grasp that that happens. Uh,
but I can tell you we worked throughout
the country, upwardly global,
and we see routinely, um, simply
bias in the hiring process. Um,
so that's why the problem exists.
And, uh, and who would exist for,
so refugees in America are we settled
in some 300 communities across the
country. So you can imagine
where some of this plays out.
Um, so one of the interesting things is
there's, there's been a big focus in,
in previous administrations, particularly
Obama administration around, uh,
employment and economic opportunity
and placing refugees into, into, uh,
into their fields program
called Partnership for
refugees with nearly 6 million
open jobs in the country.
Why do you think, you know,
what are some more of the reasons why
you feel like it's so difficult for
refugees to get placed both on the,
and we've talked a lot
about the refugee side,
but even more so potentially
on the corporate side from
your experience working
with some of the biggest,
yeah,
yeah, yeah. Um, so yeah, so
just to sort of juxtapose,
the Obama Administration was
very interested in immigrant
integration and in the
workforce. And so there was
a larger effort broadly for
immigrants and then very
specifically to bring companies
to the refugee crisis,
a corporate response called
Partnership for Refugees. Um,
I think largely companies
don't necessarily find
this population as readily,
particularly the refugees
for a number of reasons.
One is they tend to have a gap
at the top of their resume.
It could be a handful of months, it
could be a number of years. Um, uh,
and so if their most recent job is
actually the stocking shoes at Payless,
um,
when in fact they are an engineer
of some sort and we see all kinds,
um, it's unlikely that a, an uh,
somebody reviewing a resume pool is going
to understand why that gap exists and
we may make certain
assumptions about that gap.
And simply we're in competitive markets,
right? How do we screen lots of resumes?
The second is as again,
I think a very large misunderstanding
about the work authorization of certain
immigrant classes.
Refugees have a green card,
they work without visa sponsorship
as do a number of immigrant classes.
So I can't tell you how many times
we've worked with big companies,
fortune 15 companies that have said to me,
we can only hire citizens.
And I have to delicately say
that's actually an EEO violation.
Unless the position require
a security clearance,
where citizenship is necessary
for most positions in the economy,
you are not allowed to discriminate
between green card and citizenship.
And so the misunderstanding when they
see a foreign name and a foreign degree,
you know, is that this person will
needs sponsorship and we don't do that.
Um, so I think, and then the other
thing is where the channels, where are,
where are our companies going
for their talent? And you know,
so you work within networks. Um, I'm
sure he even here at Google, right?
They're strong referral culture.
Refer your friends if you're smart and
motivated and they're coming again.
So what helps refugees in the beginning,
our ethnic enclaves that support
them in language acquisition,
getting their kids in school,
ethnic groceries can also become isolating
when they're not connected to the
mainstream.
Um,
and so you do find this gap between
where they are and companies saying that
they want talent,
uh,
but not necessarily knowing where and
how and how to evaluate within the
existing processes,
the talent pool that lies within these
2 million highly skilled but under
employed immigrants and
refugees in the country.
So I guess as a followup to that, what are
some of the ways in which, you know, to,
at a policy level,
we're educating corporate leaders to be
able to understand those groups better?
Right. Um, I, I mean,
I think the larger conversation right now
is about finding talent, period, right?
So I think you see a couple of things.
I think you see a larger movement to
understanding that diversity and inclusion
happens, right? In a lot of ways
that we have to source talent from,
from a lot of venues. Um, and
in addition to that, it's,
I think really about the
companies embracing bias as
we see them trying to do,
um, and really understanding
where they may have that bias. Um,
and then I think it's really about
understanding recruiting processes and how
often are we really creating diversity
through our processes versus screening it
out. Um, but from a policy standpoint,
it's still at an individual company level.
This administration has not sought to
catalyze the corporate sector and maybe
the same way that the
last administration did.
And so it's still at a very
individual company level.
I think it's still under the broader
umbrella of companies seeking talent and
being in a moment where,
how do you assess that?
Could it come from foreign degrees?
Can it come from no degree? Right?
And we're seeing this broader sort of
idea that maybe we don't need a degree for
certain jobs in the economy and we're
just sort of inflating what is necessary
in educational attainment to
achieve certain, um, in demand jobs.
So I think that we're,
we're just trying to thread our ourselves
and the population into the larger
narrative right now that where
talent is and how we access it,
the things we have to do to get at it.
I would just say that
at a really basic level,
the fear that's going on right now,
this,
okay,
vilifying
immigrant communities,
this sense that they're pariahs rather
than looking at people as assets,
bringing in assets,
bringing in degrees,
bringing in diversity,
bringing in diversity in,
in ethnicity,
but
bringing in diversity. Even in age.
You know, America has been very,
very lucky because we're a young country
because of this influx of a million new
people every year where not Japan,
we're not Italy.
We're not suffering from a workforce to
retirement ratio like other countries
because of this. There's so
many and in many, many places.
I don't know where you are all from,
but there are many cities in America
that can talk about being revitalized
because of new ethnic communities that
have come in and are working and have
brought work and have invested
in private businesses.
And so all of that's not
part of the conversation now.
And really I hear even from people I,
I met recently with a couple of people
who are from Google and whose husbands
and wives don't have jobs,
but people are afraid to go
out now and look for jobs.
Everyone is so afraid of discrimination.
Eh, we, um,
I'm not going to overstate this statistic
understanding that I'm at Google,
but we did start to track,
we partner with employers in our program.
Our program focuses largely on the
soft skills that immigrants need,
job search skills, resume interviewing,
networking. Um, and we've,
we've made those things,
um,
such that they can do them in a self
paced way or that they can have one on one
advisory through our program. And then on
the employer side, we engage employers.
We do training for them on
who the population is. We
do some anti bias training,
but we also engage employers
and volunteer opportunities. Um,
we've done it with Google where employees
actually work as mock interviewers to
newcomers and they teach them really what
was good in the interview, what wasn't.
They get formalized feedback. It
goes into their advisory process. Um,
but we do also believe in contact
theory and even in these major markets,
upwardly global has a footprint of about
seven cities throughout the u s some
like New York and some like Boise,
Idaho.
And what's incredible is that uniformly
across that contact theory holds that
people will change their minds and their
attitudes about a certain population
after having had a personal
experience interacting with them.
And what we have found is that
some companies come to us and say,
we don't want to do any of this
employee engagement, show his talent.
And we've actually measured how many
times we present a candidate to how many
times they then interview
a candidate presented.
And we've then later gone on to have
employee engagement with that company and
measured the present to interview ratio
and seen enormous growth in the present
to interview ratio once we
have employee engagement,
meaning their employees or are interacting
with our job seekers in a meaningful
way.
Yeah.
One last question before we open it up.
And I think one of the,
one of the amazing things has been
watching over the globals growth over the
past 10 plus years,
just in terms of the amount of job
seekers they've supported from hundreds,
thousands,
uh, in, in individual year. Right.
But I know that you've done a lot of
thinking about how to scale the program
beyond that contact specific piece. Sure.
How have you done that? And you know,
with a Google audience, we always
think about bringing our product to,
to a wider audience. So
yeah. Have you done that?
Yeah. Great. Um, we,
we did it as any 21st century companies
doing it. We used more technology.
So a program that was started out being
very much in person with training.
We realized we have a population that
is very inclined to use technology.
They are highly skilled
in their home countries.
I mean 30 anywhere between 30 and 40%
of them in any given year have a masters
or better that work with us. Um, and so
we didn't have to do trainings in person.
We could absolutely use the best of online
learning and the best of technology.
So we've really tried to take everything
we were doing that we knew were
critical elements of the program and do
as much of what didn't need a human to
do through a automation technology,
robust platforms and robust online
learning management functionality. I mean,
to the point where we actually now we
were spending hours of human time taking
foreign resumes and making
them look like us resumes.
And now we just built
a resume builder tool.
It just pulls it into a US style format,
like drop the picture and then
interactive trainings that teach you what
information goes where so that at
least you can compete for the job.
Our job is not to get anybody a job is
to give them the tools to compete for the
job, which I think is very
inherently American. Um,
and we're now doing that with a technology
platform and a portal that we can
license to partners like
the resettlement system.
So if you are our IRC and you have x
number of organizations on the ground,
some of those wolverine receiving higher
volume of refugees that are highly
skilled,
but the system's not really set up as
we heard from Susan to to that work.
But some of them are
coming ready to go today.
The Iraqis are all been educated in
English. They speak English very well.
If they went to university, they don't
need necessarily to take a survival job.
Some of them are coming because
they serve the u s military forces.
They know us culture relatively well.
Um,
so you can have tools that now you
can just embed in the existing system.
Community colleges,
libraries,
even the federal workforce system is
really geared towards helping people get
really low wage, low word, uh, low
skilled work or mid skill work. Now, um,
you can actually offer it through
the system. They licensed the portal,
they licensed the resources and we're
scaling our growth that way through
productizing what we've done.
And I just want to say this,
keeping data on all of it since day one.
So the most fun, right of what we do,
um, and that I'm really excited
about for the future is that it's,
it's like these mini pathways for those
who come to the u s and the more data
you have, the more time you can help
them avoid pathways that didn't work.
A doctor who comes to the u s of a
certain age with a certain background,
a certain specialty may have decision
points in their journey in the u s should
they relicense as a physician.
So did they find an alternate degree that
may take less time and fewer resources?
I have had a higher degree of success
and we're going to start to have enough
data to look at where are they in the
u s where, where were they educated,
how long ago to give them some analysis
of what are the best ways for them to
pathway back into professional
careers that use their,
their skills and their experience and
their, we are doing a little test with a,
with a Google big data product.
So, so I would say that data that,
that distinguishes upwardly
global is incredible.
And it's the only way to counter
those stories that keep circulating.
I mean,
I'm a huge fan because of this.
I mean it's really distinguishes upwardly
global from any other service provider
in this field.
I think in this niche.
Really exciting stuff.
So I do want to open it up for audience
questions and feel free to please come
to the mic because we are
recording this talk. Um,
so we'll open it up to you guys.
I, uh, that was so great. So my
question is, do you guys have a,
a clear sort of end goal that you're
trying to achieve for any given sort of
refugee or immigrant?
Like what would be considered a success?
Like would it be a success if,
say this doctor who came
over became like a lab tech,
would it be only a success if he became
like was was still working in the
medical profession or maybe would it be
considered as success if maybe his kids
eventually like went to a really
great college and you know,
eventually went on to medical school?
And what is sort of,
how are you measuring
sort of your progress?
Great question.
Um,
so we've thought about this problem
a number of ways and you know,
I'm sort of trained right
with an economics France. So
mine is like optimization,
right? When, when are we optimized?
We have decided as upwardly global that
we're sort of in a turn of the wheel
where our goal is at least creating a
high quality system of non vulnerable
support.
And that's a fancy way of saying no matter
where you land in the u s you should
not be without a resource that can
support you understanding where and how to
rebuild your professional career.
And so this is sort of the phase we're in.
While we've done that though,
and because of the data,
what we have is a large body of
information on licensing and relicensing.
What are the barriers? Whose
relicensing? How easily?
Because remember for professions
like doctors, dentists,
lawyers, civil engineers,
there's,
and it's governed by state.
It's not even a national policy that
where you land in the u s may predict the
ease with which you can relicense.
And so I think for us,
this first turn of the wheel is about
getting what we have into the system in a
way that is not vulnerable and ubiquitous
and to be able to collect the data on
it.
And the second turn of the wheel,
it would be optimizing for
understanding the policies around um,
certification.
So who's getting jobs,
who needs to recertify and if they are
an in demand fields where certification
is necessary, what and how is most
helping them obtain those certifications?
In some cases it's financial support.
They don't have the $800 to
take a Coursera course. Again,
we're being supported by
Google to sort of fix that gap.
In some cases it's a
little more sophisticated.
It's just simply a very long
arduous process to recertify.
And there's not necessarily a benefit
to the recertification is that the
professional bodies that govern
these industries stand in the way.
So a very classic example, not to throw
the physician's assistants under the bus,
but a doctor could easily apply their
training in their home country to become a
physician assistant in the u s where
the four years that somebody with no
medical training would need should,
could be shortened.
But the physician assistant,
um,
professional industry group holds tight
that none of that previous medical
experience training or experience can
apply towards efficiency physician
assistant degree.
And they're hopefully over time our data,
we'll help if there's a movement in the
advocacy world, um, to be pushing for,
for relicensing barriers,
um, to be lowered. For me,
it would be that wherever somebody
has a skill that can contribute to the
economy,
we're not letting an issue of their
ability to compete stand in the way and
we're not letting an issue of financial
resources to obtain the proper licensing
stand in the way. If, if
I could just respond to,
I would respond to it a little bit
more broadly about resettlement. Right.
It's also about integration and
I can't emphasize that enough.
So what Nikki's addressing is something
much more as a systematic response
overall.
Right.
The resettlement agencies may get some
people certified because some of the
volunteers or support groups may
have that extra money to do this,
but she doesn't want it
to be something ad hoc.
She wants us to be something systematic
that people have. But the arc,
the, the trajectory that the resettlement
agencies have is the longterm,
which is, we've seen refugees and
immigrant communities over a longterm.
So I always say to refugees
yesterday was bad. Today may be bad,
but tomorrow will be better is that
idea of the improvement is gradual,
but it happens and they definitely
see it with their families.
But not letting people be isolated is so
critical because America will suffer if
we make people afraid and isolated and
we're seeing back and countries in Europe
and the reason we don't have
those problems is we have
absorbed people well for
hundreds of years. We shouldn't
be afraid of absorbing people.
Well, thank you. Thanks.
I would guess that like,
okay,
the more time people spend
languishing in refugee camps,
like probably the worst it is for
their eventual outcomes. Is that,
is that something you've
seen from the evidence?
Yeah. Particularly the older they
are when their journey starts.
So young people do better.
We've seen young folks complete university
pre or during even refugee camp,
um,
time in a refugee camp and then come out.
And because there is still young companies
will take a chance on them. Those,
our experience and our data,
I'm talking,
you can probably talking about the field
in general is that we've seen the older
they are, when they get in a refugee
camp in the longer they stay there.
It is indeed harder when they get out.
That's what we've experienced.
Is that the question?
Where are you going to add something else?
So, so, um,
there are more and more programs overseas
that we call livelihoods programs.
I mean, people need, people are
so anxious even psychologically.
So imagine if you're in a,
not just a camp,
but even a city where you're
just a welfare recipient
and you just want to be in
control of your life and your family.
You want a chance at a skill,
at a job,
at something.
And Actually Google supports a lot of
workforce livelihood programs all around
the world. Um, my organization,
even in a program in Israel for minorities
in that country has a Google support.
But it's so important for people even
psychologically to feel they have a skill
to have a chance,
but the need is so much greater than
the resources out there to give people
either the skills or the jobs
that they need. But you're right.
And adolescence are
particularly vulnerable, right?
Because they're growing up in this vacuum.
And that's so scary
because idle adolescence,
even in our own homes aren't a good thing.
Can you imagine in that kind of
environment? Yeah. Thank you for that.
They're right. Or young adults. Hmm.
I just want to say thank you because
your outlook on this is very positive and
that's a great narrative that actually
as someone who's worked with adolescent
refugees, that's pretty dire. Um,
obviously there's like a lot that can
be done with the data and technology and
sort of the idea of building
resumes and all of this.
But I wanted to touch a little bit more
again on what you're talking about in
terms of networking and stuff because I
feel like even for people born here and
everything, that's a huge issue
and barrier to getting jobs.
And if you could go a little bit more
into the work that you do and potentially
the more work that could be done in
terms of working with the refugees,
integrating, creating networking
opportunities for them. Because yeah,
you can be the best qualified person and
to have a spic and span resume and if
you don't know the right people,
it's just not going to happen.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean I'll,
I'll talk about two things there.
One is just teaching
again,
the gap in the system is helping newcomers
understand networking is necessary.
That it's a part of how we look for jobs
and we do it outside of our family or
our immediate community. So in other
cultures, networking might happen,
but it might happen in a little bit
more of a its family or its immediate
community.
So education is a piece of the puzzle,
just that it's done getting
people comfortable with doing it.
Any U s with us expectations.
Um,
two is the use of linkedin from an
educational standpoint. So again,
I mean we just do training on how to
use linkedin. How did you your profile,
how to optimize your profile.
Linkedin helps us with that. Um,
I think the third about networks is um,
a little bit more of the systematic too
when we see sort of like how are you
going to get people hooked in?
And so I think two things.
I think that there's a systematic response
and I think there's a community or
movement response.
The systematic response would be,
wouldn't it be great if the resettlement
system could get everybody on linkedin
profile as they're starting?
Right.
And I think the badging movement
might start to help similarly,
but in the same way you have
to have communities that
are opening their arms and
saying, we're here to help. It's got to
be a community or movement type response.
And I actually do think you see that
response companies were very engaged after
the refugee crisis here and in some cases
internationally about saying how can
we help?
And I think that idea that you're
actually extending a hand specifically as
social capital, um, first and helping
them understand what's expected,
but then in extending social capital,
um, and I know it's exactly as you say,
it's not technology.
Um,
it is the part of the work that still
has to be done because it's values based.
It's what we believe
is sort of right to do.
And because we're acting as communities
that are better being compassionate as
well as sort of a thoughtful about
economic integration and its benefits.
I don't know if you want to add to that.
So, so tell me the emphasis
of your question again.
Um, just the idea of how
you can take this. It's,
it's almost the most ephemeral part of
getting someone to jog in the u s and you
can't just figure, there's no
specific process to it. But when you,
even no matter how you try in terms of
networking and helping people with jobs
that way,
given so much of success in terms of
hiring and all of that is driven by that
very element.
So I think maybe Nicki was alluding to
it when she said the community response.
But living in New York,
you really see these themes of different
communities that have specific jobs.
So the superintendents are,
I don't want to say these things,
but are from a certain ethnic group or
the people who work in places that you
know, might be in the, um,
gas places or from a soap.
People talk to each other. Um,
technology, social media has helped.
WHATSAPP really helps, you know,
an organization's
humanitarian organizations,
resettlement agencies like IRC,
trying to work very hard and
using technology to really
help people in terms of
locating jobs, helping people
in many, many creative ways.
But I think people really,
so the,
the really neat things is refugees and
immigrants are resourceful and they're so
smart and they know how
to survive and succeed.
We just have to be careful that they're
not so afraid to be here. Right.
Like and so that they don't turn inward,
but that they go ahead and embrace
the challenges that are out there.
I don't know if I answered you,
but I think
they create dairy.
There's a whole other question about
empathy from non from the existing
communities here, but that's for
a huge though. I have to say it.
Yes.
I would say on the positive side,
so all the agencies that do this work
and definitely the resettlement agencies,
but I'm guessing even the agencies
that go beyond resettlement,
the the,
the amount of support that the American
people gave with their hands and feet in
terms of volunteers and with
their pockets in terms of money,
when the rhetoric is ramping up,
the support systems for
refugees really are amazing.
They're just not aware of it
because it doesn't get pressed.
They just keep hearing all the bad
stuff. But in America, the protections,
the support systems, the,
it's, it's incredible.
The goodwill of of America
towards these individuals I think.
Thank you.
I hope you're at
hi. Hi. Hi.
Do you have hard or soft data on what
employers find are the challenges in terms
of considering refugees or immigrants
into bringing them into their
organizations?
And is that something that you've been
able to kind of write down or you know,
is that found in a certain location in
terms of what challenges on the employer
side. Yeah. Um, and do
you have any denial? Okay,
sure. Yeah, I mean on the, and to your
question about harder stuff, data,
it's been soft until now. We just did
the first sort of official report.
Oliver Wyman actually did like a
third party report on it first.
That's embargoed for a couple more weeks.
But I can give you some
headlines to what we,
we thought was going to be there
and that we've heard over the years.
One is that it's very hard to take an
alternative candidate and advocate for
them.
There's risk involved in that as an HR
manager and even sometimes as an employee
who's advocating for a candidate.
So that gap at the top of the resume,
that education, there's no us
professional experience on the resume.
So making a case for that
candidate feels risky. And in fact,
one of the things that we've experimented
with significantly over the years is
pushing for contract work and measuring
how much of our contract work turns into
full time work for our job seekers.
And so we've seen about a 69% conversion
rate over the years from contract to
full time.
And that's because people perceive
lower risk with timebound contract work.
And so that risk perception is very high.
And getting somebody who feels safe
bringing an alternative candidate and,
and making a case for
them and probably feels,
say failing right at having
somebody fully integrate.
Then the practical challenge of it after
that I think really has to do with a
culturation and mentorship. So, um,
is there a culture of
mentorship within a company?
We've found where there's a real culture
of mentorship, they do a lot better.
We've also found that companies that
have a lot of internationally trained
people at the top, just, it's
not, the accent's not a problem.
The fact that like they're in there,
it gets spelled wrong and
emails is not a problem. Like,
what may be my mother's an
English teacher. I mean,
even when I say confusing
there with their, I'm like,
my anxiety rises. Right? Um,
but you know,
we work with a major bank,
they're an international bank and
they hire, they hire folks like crazy.
The crazy, um, because it's just
not, those things are different.
And the culture of mentorship is very
strong there. I think on the true side,
communication and acculturation is a
long and in some cases, slow process.
And so I think where we've seen employers
tell us they're struggling is like the
job seekers in, but they're not
doing particularly well, right.
In advancing their staying right there.
And so it's because they don't understand
the nuance of managing up or they
don't understand the
nuance of communications or
because more communications
have to be done remotely and it's just
not been a long enough time or they're
not coming along fast enough. And
that's just a reality. Um, so, you know,
part of,
as we've grown,
what we've done is to put more in our
resources for both companies and for the
immigrants once they have
their job. Right. Okay, great.
So there are resources for now
what we're trying, right? Yeah.
So we're a smaller organization, so
it was worth, exactly. Well, you know,
we've got 5,000 alumni now.
Um,
and we're like adding them at
a clip about a thousand a year.
And that's when we were sort of like,
oh, we have a new problem. We've got,
we've got alumni who have
to succeed in order to
for uh, you know, make way for the
those coming in. Okay. Yeah. Um, I,
I think some of what Nicky talked about,
it's also true for American born correct.
People who are struggling in,
in these survival jobs.
I would just say from a
resettlement perspective,
I think the mentoring is very important,
but many resettlement agencies try to
work with companies or employers that will
accept a liaison for a period to
make sure there aren't any problems.
And a lot of employers would like to have
somebody to go to and talk about these
things.
And then you bring in people who may
be somebodies wearing hijab or somebody
wants to go to pray. And for these
communities, it's nice to have other,
you know,
people from their parts of the world at
that same place so that they're not the
only ones there.
But
are there resources to help up those
liaisons between the four companies and
stuff like that or, or is that something
that companies define for themselves?
How does that, go ahead. We do that
in a very bespoke way right now.
So like that is part of,
so as we've,
as we've evolved our model to kind of
be technology enabled and scalable,
we focus first on the job seeker side
of this and then we still sort of do
custom custom stuff like
that with our companies.
Whereas like the second turn the wheels
about enabling companies to have a
playbook and or resources that would do
training internally like cross cultural
training for those who are going to
play that kind of a liaison for all.
So then the newcomers and refugees in
particular the resettlement agencies,
very often we'll try to do this.
And also the whole push for take your
first job so you'd have some record of
having that job. Showing up to work to us
is so important in the beginning. Right.
It's a very different place than
by the time Nikki may see them.
I guess just kind of allude to what we
were just talking about when you were
mentioning the a page resume with the
details that then interviewer cannot
legally ask about it.
It makes me wonder because I am the child
of Italian immigrants and either now I
sometimes have a difficult time explaining
to them how certain things work here
even as opposed to my
previous job. Google. Huh.
Slow ramp up in comparison.
Other software firms that
I've worked for the past.
So my question is how difficult is it to
teach the people that the job seekers,
how different America American customs
about regarding employment are and how
difficult is it for that
information to be retained?
I'm not sure how else to explain it.
Yeah, well adults are
experiential learners. Um,
and so when we said,
you know,
we tried to make as much available online
that they can be self paced in and use
the time that we have with the humans
that we have to raise money for pay to
practice. Um, and in fact,
many of the things that we practice
are the things that feel unnatural. Um,
so like you said, Italians
and I'm speaking as one. Um,
right.
Like if we were coming over from Italy,
perhaps the ways in which we
would approach your job search,
we would have to tell him some
things down and some things up.
And those are the things that we spend
time practicing because we found,
and it is largely documented
that adults learn by doing. Um,
so where we, we did a lot of
information sharing, you know,
through online learning.
We spend a lot of our in-person,
human resource time on the practice
in order to ingrain those behaviors.
And in fact we continue to try to use
and are looking forward to using more
technology that gives positive
feedback when the right behaviors are
demonstrated. Um, so when
you say how hard is it,
it does also become a
very individual thing.
I've seen 67 year old engineers come to
the u s and just decide they get it and
they're going to do it. Um,
and, and they have job. Um,
and I've seen younger, I've seen a 30
year old or rocking man, you know, just,
he's not in his face as
he's, he's, uh, you know,
usually a refugee and,
and they're struggling.
They're struggling with the culturation.
It's not their moment.
And I've seen them take a
very long time in the program.
They're simply not ready yet to sort
of accept that this is the way it is or
something like that. So I would hate to
make generalizations based on age. Um,
I tend to think it's about where we
need people in their journey or in their
process, but that it is always, for me,
what I've seen is practice and time
on task rentals, yields, results.
And then when, when you, uh,
you are also talking about automated
tools, you're building work.
The rest of my builder,
like somebody give some arrests made
with their religious affiliation on it.
You have to say you can't have that
on American resume and you got some
different because now you're not really
doing anything personal with them
directly.
How do you deal with that scenario?
Best of online learning is my
response and then an advisor.
So they do have like a horn,
like online learning can
really know it's interactive.
They see a person come on and they say,
look,
in the U s we tend not to share
personal information, you know are,
this is what a a US resume would look
like. And then we have like a help line.
So if somebody is not
progressing in their training,
we get a notification they stopped and
we then use part of our helpline capacity
to understand why they stopped.
And if it's that, you know, again,
they're not trusting, they need
to hear human voice for a second.
We've had that happen. I had somebody
who, he told me, he was like,
you guys don't know what you're talking
about. I even remember his summary.
There was a he, he wrote, and I don't
know where it went wrong in a translation,
but his lead in was, I'm an
awkward leader. Um, and I
tried desperately to say,
you know,
the pictures got to come off and awkward.
I think we're going for a different
word here. Any of, you know,
if he didn't get a response in the job
market and he came back a couple of weeks
later and few successful.
Thank you.
Are there any more questions,
if not,
just one of the things.
Okay.
[inaudible].